this is a production of cornell
university
thank you excellence well uh good
afternoon everyone and it sounds like i
am between uh
between this this group and a break and
uh
would certainly like to thank the
opportunity for uh for cornell to having
uh
having bayer as well as myself join your
your presentation
uh today my name is mark foster and uh
i'm with bare crop science and our sea
growth
business i've been with with bayer for
roughly 22 years in both the canadian
and u.s businesses as well as across
both the row crop business and our our
veg organization
and it is introduced uh i'm going to
talk a little about how how bayer crop
science
positions themselves when we're thinking
about seed treatments
and the various components that go into
our
our thought process about bringing
products to market
so first and foremost who is bayer well
of course we're a multinational company
with a focus on seed trait
chemistry and biologicals and uh
and really when you start to think about
uh the sea growth perspective of course
we really encompass all of these things
that we're talking about on this screen
uh we we have wholly owned seed brands
we uh mark i'm not seeing you share your
screen
okay hopefully you're seeing it now
perfect got it
there sorry about that so
so as bayer we we do focus through the
uh the components of our our go to
market strategy inclusive of seed
traits chemistry and biologicals and uh
target them for both an
upstream use pattern as well as a
downstream use pattern
when we're focusing on on any type of
innovation
really the vision is driven by ensuring
that that the products that we're
searching for
offer offer value to our customers
that they can be utilized in sustainable
means and then also have an
ability for utilization as we look at
more data-driven decisions
so when we're thinking about seed growth
there's a lot of things that go into
into this type of type of innovation and
investment clearly number one in order
for a customer to uh to want to do
business with with any type of company
is to provide innovation and uniqueness
within
within their their operation
the next part is of course utilizing
some
some technologies and formulations that
can be broadly adapted for many
different types of use patterns
as you all know there's there's many
different types of treating systems out
there with varying degrees of
sophistication
and the ability to apply them correctly
is going to require some
some adaptable formulations that can
make them work in varying circumstances
that leads us to application technology
we have a wholly owned division within
bayer that that
builds treater application technology
and seed treaters based in shakopee
minnesota i'll talk about here
throughout the presentation and then
lastly from a customer service
perspective
it's definitely critical that that
you're able to service the products that
you bring to market
and uh and making sure that the customer
experience is a positive one
and from our standpoint the customer is
not only the
the person selling the seed treatment
that we sell the same treatment to
whether that be a seed company or
distributor but also through
the person who's actually doing the
application and then ultimately to the
farmer who is seeing success with
utilizing the uh
the product from an efficacious
perspective
now lastly when when we're thinking
about the marketplace
as mentioned we we are a uh a provider
of seed within the the global
marketplace and one of our largest
customers at bearcrop science is our
wholly owned brands
uh this gives us a great opportunity to
test run the formulations that we need
to make sure that they
they can be applied correctly and in
addition to it gives us
an opportunity to make sure that
customers are are able to see a pathway
to uh
to utilize the product not only there
will be a seed company we are a
chemistry provider
uh the seed growth space is a very small
world where uh
there's there's a today to finite number
of active ingredients
and we also want to make sure that
there's an opportunity to work with
other other providers out there
as mentioned we're an equipment
manufacturer and ultimately the success
of our products rely on application
being successful as well
and the investment that we have in uh in
creating application technology that's
sustainable
and and efficient is important and then
lastly making sure that we have end use
confidence now
just to maybe focus on what is an
example of success
and why these things get a little bit
more complicated
in this top right hand corner you see
some of the things that we're really
trying to do
as an example of a soybean seed
treatment we're really looking at
roughly eight to nine different
components
in very small scale that we're applying
to a seed in order to have the
the expression of of efficacy to control
varying degrees of pests or promote
growth in the case of biologicals
to be illustrated within a farmer's
situation
when we start to talk about these these
seven eight or
even up to nine different types of
products that we're putting on the seed
being able to do so on a on a finite
amount of real estate within the seed is
extremely important
with the development example through
equipment you can see a
a picture of a bayer on-demand treater
which allows for varying components to
be applied to specific
seeds at a at a very a controlled rate
and a very quantifiable rate
as you can see a closed system a closed
system that doesn't allow for
significant exposure to the user and is
ultimately a clean means of of doing so
while relying on loss-of-weight
measurements to ensure accuracy that the
amount of seed treatment that is being
applied to those
particular components is being done in
an accurate measure
so while we have many of those
components and we have ways to to apply
them
in an accurate means we we also have to
make sure that when we do put it into
the drum of the treater that the
the treatment itself goes on to the seed
and not
become sticky within the bowl or within
the uh within the drum
so success at the end of the day is
really having uh
that's that product you're applying go
from the chemistry jugs
onto the seed and not being upheld by
the by the
metal surrounding the application means
the next step of course is then taking
it from that treater and putting it
through the planter
and in a means of testing you want to
make sure that
uh all of those varying components still
allow flow ability
uh they don't bridge up within a
planting system which ultimately creates
time and and costly efforts on behalf of
a farmer
in order to get that planted seed into
the field
and then lastly of course the the proof
is always in the results
and when when we do get the seed into
the field we want to make sure that the
products do control the pests that they
perform
and and say that they will control and
ultimately lead to a farmer being
set up for a successful harvest
now from a a a four pillar type of
approach it really all starts with the
formulations that you're working with
and as we're considering these things we
have full formulations inclusive of
fungicides
insecticides adding seed coatings and
finishers
so things like fluency agent advanced to
ensure that we have flow ability
as mentioned in the previous speaker
biologicals are also added to the uh
to the uh the formulation and into the
into the actual application
and then ultimately making sure that the
formulation is stable
we need to make sure that we can ship
these products to the applicator and
they'll be able to maintain
uh their longevity and be able to manage
some
some more adverse conditions such as
higher heat temperatures or lower
lower temperatures to avoid freezing and
thawing
but ultimately maintaining their
viability to make sure they can
be used effectively and lastly another
pathway to that is through custom blends
which is ultimately the layering of
individual assets in fully formulated
means
one on top of the other and then can be
mixed together for a for an application
at point of of time
when we're thinking about that
application means we we do run all of
these things through our labs
and then at a pilot scale in our in our
research facility and then we move it on
to a
a full-fledged scale treater at uh
at a pilot plant our labs are located in
st
louis do this on a small scale to ensure
proof of concept
and then in our pilot facilities we have
scaled down versions of
full-sized treaters to make sure that
they do work in either a batch treatment
or a continuous flow type of
type of experience then the final step
is to uh
to take it to commercial treaters and as
mentioned we know that
while we build seed treaters ourselves
at bayer
we want to make sure that they have
functionality with a vast array of
application technologies that do exist
and when we're doing all these things
we're first and foremost considering
seed safety
putting this putting these chemistries
on the seed it's important they don't
hurt the
the efficacy of the seed from a
germination perspective
as mentioned by your previous speaker we
want to make sure that they uh
the chemistries can can work together
and don't uh
necessarily have antagonism when they're
when they're mixed together in a slurry
uh formulating recipe creations in in
utilization of those coatings and
finishers
and then ensuring that we have field
testing that that has been
accomplished to ensure that they they
work correctly
from an equipment perspective this this
varies anywhere from what i've called
inside the bag as well as some outside
the bag type of opportunities commercial
of course is when
upstream companies or c companies are
applying the product for you
generally this is a means professional
application
and then the formulations also need to
be able to work in an outside the bag or
downstream mentalities which is very
common in in soybeans and cereals
ultimately this equipment we want to
make sure is accurate
can be applied in a in a safe means from
a stewardship perspective and then from
a sustainability
uh component that they're applied in a
means that
that put the seed treatment on the seed
and that treatment stays there
and then lastly a full service portfolio
is important whether that be from the
development of the product in our field
solutions
organizations or uh technology
development all the way through to uh
to ensuring that the customer has a very
satisfied
product uh in the field
now just a couple more slides here that
i wanted to go through as to a bit of
the complexity
on the formulation development one of
the things that we take for granted is
ultimately we're trying to put
as many solds as we possibly can into a
liquid
and make sure they will still pump and
then hold themselves
to to the the seed once it's applied
as you can see within a formulation the
active ingredient portion
is is really about a quarter of it
and and beyond that you have several
other components that make the
formulation of viable
products be utilized whether that be
pigments or buffers
anti-foaming agents or de-dusting agents
and really getting the mix of those
products correct
uh is really what's going to ultimately
have the best
uh best utilization for your end user
the active and green of course you're
working on making sure that it is going
to control the pests or or promote the
growth that you're you're actively
intending to do
uh from a disbursement we're making sure
that it will stay in
in the uh in the means of of liquid that
you want it to be staying in
and then ultimately from water and
solvent and filler that's to make sure
that it will uh
will flow within the certain formulation
that you've built
as well as then adding adjuvants and
rheological aids to
to make sure that they they do perform
in means of suspension and
application that you're searching to do
ultimately as mentioned you can see the
varying different types of things that
you're attempting to do
and uh whether that be adding solos to
liquids or oils it's
it's extremely difficult to do in a
concentrated means that is still able to
be utilized by our end customer through
the application means
now after we've got that formulation
built i'd mention the next element is to
make sure that we can
apply these products in a a way that is
going to ensure that there is
good stewardship as well as proper
efficacy
of the product ending up in the intended
active ingredient load
different types of means are done but
it's a couple of core measurements for
us are ensuring that dust and dust off
is well under control
with the formulations and if any tweaks
would need to be done
through d dusters or additions for that
and what you can see here from an
application standpoint in the bottom
left-hand corner
is particularly when you get to on-farm
applications not all seed quality
is uh is necessarily uh
industrial grade if you will so you have
to make sure your formulation is able to
be optimized to work with
with varying degrees of of seed quality
going in
and as you can see the in the bottom
corner we've we've
attempted to work with both uh highly
highly cleaned conditioned seed and then
and then some stuff that is maybe a
little bit more uh
uh or i should say less refined
after you've put the product on the seed
we we run it through some
seed flow ability testing ultimately
this is to ensure that it doesn't bridge
when it's within
within its planting technology or going
through the
the augers into the planter this is
definitely a pain point for consumers
if they do experience any of that type
of issue and in particular in the
planting situation
and uh what we know is that the
viscosity can change of that seed after
we applied these
these products to them so seed flow
ability is extremely important
and then the other thing i just talked
about is the the coverage so
uh ensuring that the uh there's enough
liquid
and uh application technology to ensure
that we have ideal coverage to the
entire seed
as some of these products are are
more of a contact rather than a systemic
and it's important to make sure that you
have good coverage
of of every every opportunity of that
that particular seed now lastly i just
want to talk a bit about our
our equipment focus here um
we've certainly seen tremendous
innovation when it comes to equipment
bayer has uh of course mentioned we have
upstream type of application equipment
through commercial plants
but there's also a need for uh for
downstream type of equipment
and clearly in the top left hand corner
you see examples of
of probably a little bit more
unorganized type of treatment location
and and we could probably all agree that
there's uh
some things we'd rather not see in that
picture below that is the the bayer on
demand
which controls the amount of chemistry
being being uh
applied to the sea but it's also a
closed system
opportunity where it's just really done
through the pumping
stands and and loss and flow measurement
of the chemistry
being applied through the atomizer this
uh this type of technology is all done
in the shakopee location where there's a
135
000 square foot facility built to
construct both upstream and downstream
equipment
of varying levels of of control and
scale
so we're very fortunate to have have
this investment to be able to utilize
the the top to bottom integration of
creating a formulation
but also being able to apply it the core
elements of of the equipment business is
really from application
uniformity as well as utilizing the
formulation to make sure it goes through
the equipment
but our true areas of emphasis are on
stewardship user safety
and then value assurance that the
product is going on to the product
onto the seed correctly and then lastly
from a regulatory compliance
it is very important that we use these
products at the appropriate rates
and uh and be mindful if they do get to
the seed
correctly so really in summation from a
a customer success standpoint
our goal here at bayer is to have
products that move
from a plantability perspective have
user safety
have considered stewardship
considerations
and then offer value to customers
through efficacious approaches to
to insects and and diseases
as well as offer means of applying
varying
biological components so with that i'm
going to maybe hit pause
and and see if there's any questions
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu